[Music]
don't worry
i'll be right back
the frenchman's and the car given to us
thirty thousand dollars what's going on
[Music]
hello hello
so you're not telling me what you're
doing here i'm looking for my sister
i heard she's with the ypg now
[Music]
the legends are all true the women of
the ypj will stop at
nothing in their fight against isis
he who is killed by a woman on the
battlefield
there is no heaven this is why we came
to the caliphate
to prove our conviction and i'll do what
needs to be done
were you followed did you say your
sister's name was anna hubbard he said
she died in a terror attack two years
ago
the real question is if your sister is
here killing isis
how come everyone thinks she's dead
what will you do if you find her
i guess i'll have a lot of questions
coming here was a big mistake
[Applause]
i should never all come here at the end
of the day
you're british you were recruited to
save lives back at home
if your sister's here she's fighting
with people she loves
to save people she loves
in 36 hours we attack the enemies of god
when ypg marches earth and heavens
tremble
[Music]
you should have gone home when you had
the chance i want to help
we always knew this was a one-way ticket
the pressure's getting to you too much
you need to tell me
no i want to finish the mission
i'm not living without my sister